welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition I hear your
friendly neighborhood spoiler man and
this video were breaking down Iron Man 3
we discussed the first two films in the
Tony trilogy last week and this really
is the cherry on top in terms of Easter
eggs throughout this video we're going
to be breaking down many of the movies
parallels the scenes that don't pay off
until much later in the saga and some of
the things that you may have missed this
isn't a fully extensive list as the
movies being taken apart more than
Tony's armor but it should cover some of
the best ones that you only notice after
binge watching the MCU
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check out all of the Infinity Saga
movies then I highly recommend that you
check out now please drop a thumbs up if
you enjoy the breakdown and make sure
you subscribe to the channel for videos
like this every day without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into Iron Man 3
okay so Iron Man 3 whilst not the
culmination of Tony Stark's arc in the
MCU is the closing of his trilogy we've
already talked about how the character
had a similar origin story in some ways
to Captain America both were left with
nothing but due to their heart and a
friendly scientist they were able to go
beyond their shortcomings these
similarities were even shown in the
death of their mentors but you may not
have noticed that their trilogies also
end in a similar sort of way in fact
each character in the Trinity of the MCU
heroes made up of Iron Man Captain
America and Thor all have a lot of
things that line up for example Tony has
a weakness and that is his arc reactor
he had to use it to save his heart but
at the end of Iron Man 3 he gets rid of
it after finally finding a way around it
he destroys his suits in order to save
his relationship and turns his back on
being Iron Man in the Captain America
trilogy
Steve's main weakness is his friend
Bucky and at the end of his trilogy he
ends up throwing away the relationship
that he's built with the rest of the
Avengers in order to save his friend
Civil War culminates with him throwing
away his shield and he turns his back on
being Captain America but he manages to
say Bucky from hydras mind control in
the Thor trilogy those main weakness is
his relationship with his brother Loki
sorry
adopted brother and Loki is able
trick him several times and betray him
because Thor trusts him so much this is
similar to how Steve constantly sticks
with Bucky even though he does some bad
things as the Winter Soldier at the end
of the Thor trilogy he manages to repair
his relationship with his brother and
similar to Iron Man and cap who both get
rid of their main weapons Thor loses
Moliere realizing the true power comes
from within so yeah lots of nice
parallels where the characters all sort
of mirror one another as for the movie
itself it opens with Tony saying that we
create our own demons whilst this is
definitely the case in this film it's
something that's followed stock
throughout the entire MCU in Ironman
Warren he refused to work alongside
Obadiah and this eventually caused the
character to turn bad in Iron Man to
Justin Hammer just wanted to work with
Tony but he pretty much cast him to the
side and ended up causing him to become
an enemy in Iron Man 3 a similar
situation to hammer happens with Killian
and of course Tony would later go on to
create Ultron Tony create his own demons
to the point that even has repercussions
on the other characters we of course now
that he led to both the vulture and
Mysterio being formed but it goes far
beyond that Tony is one of the main
causes of the Avengers falling apart and
in some ways them not being together to
take on Thanos allowed the events of
infinity war to play out which cost the
lives of half the universe so it's
somewhat of a poetic way to start the
finale of his trilogy as we know this
line would have everlasting effects in
the larger MCU you know it's like poetry
they rhyme anyway we cut to burn and we
see happy Hogan looking like Vince Vega
from pulp fiction
we also witness the meeting of Tony and
dr. yinsen which was told to the
character in Iron Man 1 yinsen said that
if he was as strong as Tony was then he
wouldn't remember him either and yet
fair enough
the guy had had a few Tony also shakes
hands with dr. Wu who would end up
removing the arc reactor from the
character's chest at the end of the
movie the movie was actually changed for
Chinese audiences and had a lot of
scenes added including an extra one with
Wu and his assistants Fan Bingbing both
are big Chinese stars so these elements
were added to attract overseas audiences
Tony's name badge says You Know Who I am
which is of course a play on the
catchphrase I am Iron Man I featured at
the end of the first film the end of
this movie and at the end
game yinsen says perhaps another time
and you bet your life buddy you'll be
meeting again we can also hear this song
I'm blue by Eiffel 65 though this is
pretty Abbey it actually has a hidden
meaning to it about a man who who is
blue as in down and it's he's so blue
that it's reflected in everything around
him this is of course similar to Tony
who though on the outside seems up being
positive is dealing with the PTSD from
the Battle of New York that's our big
reach of the video I swear he meets Maya
Hansen who in the comic books co-created
extremis with Killian much in the same
way that the movie plays out
we learned that Killian is the founder
of aim and he goes to hand Tony a
business card but Tony allows my to take
it if you've been watching our breakdown
so far then you'll know that Tony
doesn't like to be handed things the
first time this was shown was an Iron
Man 2 at the store where he was summoned
to the Senate lair in the movie it
happened when he was being served
strawberries and in Avengers had
happened that stark towers and the
interaction with Coulson the only time
that we found outside of Iron Man 1
where he's ok with taking things his
flowers from his father in endgame we've
often wondered why this is and after
going back in rewatching Iron Man 1
after doing my breakdowns I think
because normally when this happens it
brings bad news with it in that film
Christine Everhart gave him some
photographs of the damage that his
weapons had done and in Civil War which
happens after the events of this film on
my ad it's to show how bad the Avengers
are we don't know for definite exactly
what's going on with this character
trait but as this is the finale of the
trilogy I thought I'd offer up my
thoughts my takes the card and this is
how she not Tony ends up working with
him now this is sort of where the
Incredibles parallels start shouts super
wizard magic for spotting that there are
a ton of similarities in the film
including a character that idolizes the
hero becoming the villain a relationship
being rocked a character and eating
together a suit back and so on
there's tons of them so definitely
Google out because it's way too much to
talk about and to get all of the Easter
eggs in in one video it's sort of like
poetry they rhyme we also see Maya
wearing Tony's glasses after he gives
them to her and this would later be
reflected in Peter who takes the Edith
glasses cut
the present and tony is injecting
himself with tech that will allow his
armor to fly directly to him i don't
know if this is an idea that he got from
thor but the idea of having a weapon fly
- you definitely apes the god of them
disabilities the character is also seen
practicing wing chun which is a
real-life fighting technique that downey
has actually studied if you remember our
Civil War breakdown and you'll know we
talked about how he uses that when
fighting Captain America we also learn
in an article in Iron Man 1 that his
robot arm was his first invention and
the small text told us that it was
called dummy here we see it wearing a
dunce hat carrying for the notion that
it's stupid well but it's ok buddy I
still love you now I have seen some
Easter eggs on reddit that said Tony
doesn't have a cut lip but he does after
attaching the face mask the FID is back
I can actually trace this to as a user
called ie9 wdg which I hope I pronounced
right who noticed it 3 years ago after
watching the 4k version of the film on a
60-inch TV you know how we do you can
see that his lip was cut before the
helmet went on though it's very so I
also think there's a continuity error
with there as I noticed that the lip
isn't cut when he meets Rhodey but it is
through the rest of the movie showing
that the makeup department needs to get
fired anyway the manner in broadcast has
ten rings similar to the banner in the
first film that was shown in the hostage
video and we also see that Trevor wears
10 rings on his fingers he talks about
Americans stealing the land from Native
Americans and then calling it theirs
which could be a hint to how Trevor has
taken a medal of the Mandarin I don't
know if this was intentional at the time
either but we now know that the real
Mandarin is going to be in shang-chi so
it could also be a nod to howl Killian
took the name from the villain the
president is known as Matthew Ellis
which may be a nod to Warren Ellis who
wrote the extra mists storyline
we are also introduced to iron patriot
which is the new version of war machine
we learned that this armor was actually
created by aim
Killians company and he likely got this
contract through the vice-president we
learn is helping him later in the movie
him creating the armor also shows how
his henchman is able to Don the suit
without any training and calm
the mid-air hijack when Tony meets
Rhodey he talks about how he built a
device that is able to catch explosions
in the air throughout our breakdowns
we've spoken about how Tony constantly
upgrades his tech every movie to stop
himself from running into problems some
great examples of this are how he
changes from his nanotech shield to an
energy one in endgame after using it
against Stannis an infinity war pretty
much depleted his armor the Hallie
carriers and when to soldier also end up
using Jets at the Tony became stuck
under one of the turbines in Avengers
here he's developed this so he doesn't
have to fly into space again and risk
his own life should a nuke be fired at a
city we see a kids drawing of the Battle
of New York which is of course a
reference to the Battle of New York and
Tony actually climbs back inside the
suit from that movie to calm himself
down so yeah nice little Easter Egg that
shows it's a sort of a little security
blanket from that film
Killian shows pepper the inside of his
brain and the holographic techy uses and
the Blue Dot layout is similar to Tony
discovering the new element in Iron Man
2 we see Tony dumping the mark 42 below
the wine cellar in his house and we can
also see that he has numerous suits
hidden below which is a tease for the
ending Tony also looks up Killian and we
can see that through his phone aim is
flipped to MI a which hints at how he
ends up missing in action in the movie
yes we're back to reaching pepper wears
a very light lilac / white suit and
these have sort of become the colors of
the character throughout the series most
of the movies she wears these colors and
make sure you liked the video if you
enjoy men that have a a paunch wand for
fashion anyway speaking of fashion
Tony sleeps in his black vest that we've
also seen throughout the series this
always appears when the character is at
his most vulnerable and it's been a
motif throughout his entire journey he
initially wore an Iron Man 1 in the cave
when building the Mach 1 armor in Iron
Man 2 when he was at death's door due to
palladium poisoning he wore it when
trying to discover a new element that
would save his life here he wears it
when suffering from PTSD and from that
point onward he has to rebuild his
mental state from a point of
vulnerability he also wears it in
Avengers endgame when he and nebula are
adrift in space and it's nice that this
tank top pops back up to signify where
the character is at mentally he always
comes back though and he could say it
like poetry they rhyme anyway happy
barely survives the explosion and once
more we get a video from the Mandarin
and talking about fortune cookies and
how they're actually American this one
someone could be a nod to the cultural
appropriation motif Tony records a
message for the Mandarin and then
destroys the phone which yeah that
message is going nowhere mate the
Mandarin still gets his address probably
because of all the cameras about but
also likely because Killian already
knows it also shouts tater salad on
reddit for noticing this within the last
month when Tony is scanning for heat
signatures you can actually see one from
Springfield MO which is the same place
that ego planted a seed and guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 so they are likely the
same source Maya shows up to see Tony
and Killians helicopters come in too
Tony saves pepper using his suit to
rescue her and he later gives her her
own soon end game called the rescue suit
another interesting thing that happens
at this point is that Tony takes down
one of the helicopters by taking a
rocket out and throwing at the aircraft
before shooting it pepper also does this
at the end of the film to fight Killian
and this shows that she may have learned
this move from Tony Tony escapes with a
little helping hand and he goes to
Tennessee upon landing he records a
message for pepper which he has to do
through a payphone this reaches the
helmet and pepper is able to listen to
it we see him leaving another message in
a helmet to pepper at the stove end game
and of course to Morgan and the family
at the end of the movie he also meets
Holly kina
who is of course the character that
shows up at Tony's funeral at the end of
endgame Tony also visits a mural set up
for the victims of an extremis explosion
I don't know if it's just me but I got a
lot of flashes of the mural from far
from home which we see in honor of Tony
Tony gets at the bottom of the extremis
mystery and he's attacked by Killians
forces Tony shoots Killians henchmen in
the head seemingly killing him but if
you look carefully you can see him
blinking which shows that he didn't
really die and could be healed we see
Stanley playing bingo and Tony meet
someone that modeled themselves on him
you might laugh but I actually bought
some Edith glasses this month and the
wife doesn't let me wear them outside
now but I'd also feel like an idiot
anyway Tony finds the extremis footage
and
a lot of foreshadowing - pepper being
put in the program as the woman Tony
just killed is seen with long red hair
do not write this boy is reaching I'm
telling you it's like poetry
they rhyme little boy iron lad tells
Tony to just build something when he
doesn't know what to do and this is how
the character has solved his problems in
the past except for endgame in which he
was saved by Captain Marvel which is one
part of the movie that I didn't really
like Tony goes the Mandarin compound and
finds Trevor the truth does a bit of
Wing Chun and then carries out the
airplane rescue now can we just give it
up for one of the best scenes in the MCU
as well it's nice to see a superhero
movie where they actually have a full
scene dedicated to just saving people we
get a big twist at the end of the scene
when we learn that tony was using the
suit as a drone and this is something
that you learned from Vanko and Iron Man
- who said the famous lines drone better
Tony launches the suits from underwear
the wine-cellar was and we get the big
fight at the end this scene has been
broken down tons of times and all of the
suits have been discussed in depth so I
don't want to retread old ground but a
couple of interesting ones pop up
firstly the Mach 41 is able to dissemble
and reassemble and as it's the 41 it was
built before the 42 and shows that this
design carried over we also see a
spacesuit as well which Tony likely
developed after the events of the
Avengers in that his suit started to
lose power and almost shut down so it
makes sense that he would make a suit
designed precisely for that kind of
environment also we see a larger and
bulkier suit that sort of looks like the
prototype of the Hulk Buster which we
would of course see again in age of
Ultron and infinity war an end game Tony
also calls the Mach 42 the prodigal son
when it arrives and as we said in our
Ironman one breakdown this is likely a
callback to the line at the award show
in which Tony is called the prodigal son
Tony fights Killian and uses the mark 42
to blow him up and then we get the
pepper scene which calls back to the
helicopter
she also destroys the mark 7 from the
Avengers which could symbolize Tony's
PTSD being taken with it - Tony takes
the extremis our pepper
she sells some scented vagina candles
and he also gets the arc reactor remove
you can see the scars of this operation
on his chest in Civil War and slightly
an endgame carrying over from this
operation
Tony uses the shrapnel from his heart to
make a symbolic heart necklace which he
then gives to pepper this balcony scene
calls back to the balcony scene an Iron
Man and which I think the character
first realized that he liked her Tony
throws the arc reactor into the ocean at
his home and this entire scene was
actually a full a CGI head replacement
for Robert Downey jr. who was in jail at
the time whilst it looks like he's
finally given up on being Iron Man he
finds a screwdriver showing that he will
continue building he saves dummy
thank God and the movie ends with him
saying I am Iron Man which would of
course become a line not synonymous with
the characters chapter ends it ended his
first film this movie and were the words
that he carried out before doing the
snap the post-credits scene reveals that
Tony was talking to Bruce Banner at the
end of the film and getting therapy from
the character Bruce Banner is of course
the Hulk which ties in with the Hulk and
yadda yadda yadda it's like poetry they
rhyme and that's the Iron Man trilogy
obviously I loved hear your thoughts on
the breakdowns and if there's any Easter
eggs that should have made the list
comment below and let us know and if you
enjoyed this video then please drop a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our breakdown of Iron Man which is gonna
be linked at the end I think it's one of
our best videos and you should watch
this entire series so yeah go check it
out now if you want to support the
channel from as little as a 99 cents a
month and also please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate you and there's
a thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
description below those are the best
ways to keep it to date with the channel
so hopefully we see over there very soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]